some people do and that doesn't matter
that's that's your life I I had a friend
that went viral actually because she was
stuck between two fat people let's talk
about the rule the average person's fat
because they eat too much would you
personal trainer would you agree with
that 100 okay like why does this level
of delusion exist go on all right go
ahead
do you ever get dressed and just be like
damn I look good
do you ever get dressed go girl
confidence
you do your thing my
mind
[Music]
I think you guys are liars nah I'm not
you know why I'm not liar let's be real
yeah I wanna sell confidence self-love
is all you need in this world I don't
care what you don't think I don't care
I wanna hear answers from you first
before I answer this question go on no
no okay oh I I think that
um you're a liar I think you're a big
liar yeah
um and the reason I think that is
because you know damn well she don't
look good you know damn well you would
not wife her you know damn well you you
probably wouldn't even sleep sorry it's
not about the look at all she's at a
very high risk of our health conditions
right now high risk
of being obese yeah but who cares she
loves herself and that's true that
matters which is understood but do you
love yourself by killing yourself some
people do and that doesn't matter that's
that's your life if you want to choose
to you live your life what you live your
life that's up to you my friend hey I'm
great I would say I would say liar okay
South I think one it's selfish to be fat
everybody's gotta look at you
no
seriously
let me finish okay because one she goes
on an airplane what happens and the
Flubber goes over the street
she should have to but a lot of times I
have I I had a friend that went viral
actually because she was stuck between
two fat people who wanted two seats what
is that the one who requested two seats
from the airline I I don't know she I
don't know if she ended up doing that it
was Sydney Watson I did like a vice
panel with her she went viral yeah yeah
yeah because she because the blubber and
then on top top of that if you make
those choices someone's got to take care
of you so if she is fat either the
Health Care system so all you're making
the nurses all take care but sometimes
the health conditions
occasionally it is a health condition
okay can we all right I just need I need
for this conversation for us not to talk
about exceptions let's talk about the
rule the average person's fat because
they eat too much would you personal
trainer would you agree with that 100
okay so I used to be a personal trainer
okay so I can also elaborate on that all
right we could we could not understand
what you're saying I just feel like for
me yeah like a lot of the times like
it's health conditions as well because
obesity you know and there's certain
health conditions that that allow you to
to put on weight or certain medications
you may be on medication or something
and I'm a lot you know makes you put on
weight I'm unfortunately it's not your
food it doesn't mean you're eating all
day let me just be real that much weight
but do you know the situation but do we
know her situation can we can we do
again we're trying to talk about the
rule we're gonna go back and forth all
day if we say but that accepts it it's
very it's a bit frustrating sir I had a
question actually because when we're
doing the illusion a lot of people
excluded obesity so I don't know
doesn't necessarily mean I'm I'm fit to
sit here and judge someone's lifestyle
decisions but that's like exactly that's
like why would you want to be with
someone obese because it's not my
preference I don't I personally don't
find that attractive okay
then why are you supporting it I'm not
support I'm not supporting it but I'm
definitely no you're not supporting it
sit here and be rude say mean comments
for the sake of it like if she has
self-love and confidence for that's
crazy that's an inspiration confidence
exactly that's an inspiration that's
what I'm rating it's not an insult it's
not delusion it's not well
I don't think the topic is about how
confidence or her emotional topic was
about her weight but has nothing to do
with me okay so I actually wouldn't want
to get to that way but yeah how can I
judge her if she doesn't mind
system is is a point yeah I think it's
selfish to be that fat but what is your
question is what I want to know my
question is why do we allow women to
live in this level of delusion where we
parade them on social media for being
chronically obese and clearly like if a
girl was anorexic and she she came
forward and said oh I look so good today
we would say no that's not healthy but
when an obese woman does it you guys
cheer it on back in the day though like
a lot of the supermarkets we're not
talking about back in the day we're
talking about now all right so I think
personally
um
you know we live in this world now where
a lot of things are accepted without our
control and for me but for yourself yeah
I'll control myself right but we're not
talking about if I'm attracted or not
I'm looking at a video of a person that
is extremely happy with herself and as
as actually looking at herself and
thinking I look good and so you should
feel that way because I'm not gonna
accept uh from anybody telling me I'm a
fat piece of [__] oh I'm this and that
because then in the day that's your
opinion yeah but I am as good as I feel
and that's how it is opinion to say that
you need to lose weight it's not good
for your health yeah but that's her
choices
her choices affect everybody else and it
also it also shows like what we see in
the media like why are we pushing fat
women as models why are we pushing fat
women because of magazines no no because
we shouldn't be pushing that in a
society we should like do you care it
depends
yeah but she was obese and you guys
cheered it on like that that is
it wasn't the weight that we were
cheering on it was it was the confidence
and the self-love that she had
regardless of her sister that's like
that's narcissist
is an actual problem
it is a problem I said it could be
underlying health issues I said that and
if according to what she said if we
support people like that that we only uh
sorry encouraging them to maintain the
way they are
and that Holyfield no but yeah they are
but you can't help certain people that
gain that weight like I said it could be
x amount of reasons why but no no no no
no but I'm saying so you know some
people take medications that men can put
on weight you know some steroids no not
just steroids just the Apple things
I don't know but I'm saying okay so
you're speaking on something you don't
even know okay fair enough but I'm
saying I'm saying but it's not just
eating I know someone with no thyroid
that's okay she literally doesn't have
one
it wouldn't be just eating though no no
but I'm asking you you don't even know
so I'm asking you what name them name
the medication I'm not a doctor I can't
name the medication it could be a
backlash to that era where supermodels
were a lot of them were anorexic could
just be like we're going through that
and then it will balance out again maybe
no no
come on but I mean let's just be real so
you think people are obese because they
just eat here's my question yes 90 or 95
yes is a bad diet choice
okay 95 yeah others is uh health
conditions where you know you this is
there isn't involved because of the
health condition I guess steroids caused
them to gain more weight or eat more
the last time I researched it was the
minority that I had tough yeah actually
and I have a question you said um you're
only as good as you feel but aren't you
only as good as you are
but that's that's that but this is what
I'm saying because like otherwise it's
delusional so if I go around wait wait
so if I go around and I say I'm a
millionaire oh I'm A Millionaire I'm a
millionaire I'm a millionaire but I have
zero dollars in my bank account how am I
not delusional but women will go around
saying I'm beautiful I look great this
this and this when it's clearly not true
everyone in this room knows it's not
true everyone in the room wait wait
everyone in the room knows she's
delusional everyone in the room knows
that you would not want to look like her
but we cheer it on why why because
because like you gotta be happy for
someone except in who they are and if
you encouraging somebody to to be like
oh well you're fat you're undesirable
what are you doing today
it's all about you wait wait so it's all
about you as a person so I I've been
pretty overweight I was over 200 pounds
at one point and literally do you know
what made me switch was all the guys
laughing at work how they wouldn't date
a girl over 200 pounds and I was like oh
my God that's their opinion no no no but
I was good I was so glad I heard that
because I made a change but everybody
lying that's why I said liars and
cheering her on it's like you're not
telling them the truth and sometimes the
truth hurts but you make better
decisions because of it I just want to
say something fast like sorry um
so because it happened to my mom quad
footbed she has to go to the oh well
because it happened to my mom you have
to go to the doctor and see the doctor
and he doctors like you're in such a
high-risk health condition that you have
to lose weight now would that person
feel good that they was being supported
by all these people telling them that be
confident love yourself continue
doing what you're doing maintain your
weight feel the way you're supposed to
feel because that's your choice
love yourself
I think it's poor important that they
are also informed and educated I guess
the government tries to do that and also
if we're if we're comparing it to
anorexia which is an eating disorder
which is linked to mental health is
being obese not the same thing it's an
eating disorder which is mental health
which is something that is the serious
matter it's actually a habit that's
something the
nobody can help apart from that person
like because if that person has a mental
health issue and on that day they decide
to get on camera and big up themselves
then guanyu because if you're going
through all of that to get to where you
are now why don't you why don't you ask
him because he's the personal trainer
but like so so are you a mental health
coach as well are you an expert right
okay so you're only topic of mental
health yeah because we compared to
anorexia anorexia is an eating disorder
which is linked to mental health so if
if obesity is also an eating disorder
which would then be linked to mental
health which means it's a mental health
condition because part of personal
training is we have to go through life
coaching um courses as well
all of that we all have mental problems
sitting here we all have mental problems
a habit
she have developed a habit which is part
of mental problems
what you do on a daily basis is a habit
do you think it's heard the tree as well
huh do you think it's something that's
passed down as well because that's
another thing that would be because yeah
it's you know I think it goes back to
the moms yeah not teaching the kids how
to eat yeah no but like some kids are
born obese so how do you how do you
explain no they're they're not no but
like okay you know what I'm saying
there's some kids that are like okay can
we just okay I need to wait wait wait so
so let's let's just be honest the mom
feeds the kid so if the kid I would go
as far to say that if your kid's obese
then honestly that's child abuse because
you're putting that kid that that's a
hard life to be obese overweight as a
child sorry I wanted it to get back to
you like it's like a smoker right every
day you'd see it oh because you you
can't stop smoking you have mental
health no because no eating disorders
it's not but eating disorder is nothing
like smoking I guess anorexic people
think that they Well normally I think or
usually they don't see their way so they
actually don't realize how skinny they
are whereas I don't know wait wait wait
wait I heard that before so you don't
think she didn't yeah
possibly possibly yeah possibly
possibly but why but why are we fat
Shaman though is my question is why are
we fat shaming it's like discrimination
isn't it
I don't think we are human at all no but
I feel like that is though
I I think no am I the only one that
feels that way yeah I don't think I
support every single thing that you guys
will see with her love and also her
feeling confident and everything look
I'm just praising how she feels about
herself
beauty is in the eye of the beholder
some people would find a desirable no I
support that 100 it's like pretty people
find this as I say active what I do not
support this and we cannot take this too
mental health God forbid if she is to
end up in the hospital any doctor was
like you're in a health condition at
high risk where you have to lose weight
how are you going to feel knowing that
you are supporting that person
it's not really supporting though yeah
it's you're not trying to tell but it's
not completely different aspect of it
okay okay what about people that are
born like they're faces
mental and physical is too big
difference we have to understand that
it's too big difference we're not
talking about Mentor we're talking about
no at the end of the day I'm supporting
how she feels about herself
we need to realize that beauty is in the
eye of the beholder because everyone
looks different not everyone is born
with the same Faith okay do you okay
okay I have a question do you think
you're equally as attractive as that
woman on screen the thing is it depends
do you think that most men would find
you more attractive or her more
attractive
please please don't please just make
this please
I know you know the answer please
but why is it about comparison
please
yeah it's please I don't I just don't
feel comfortable even answering
something like that because you know the
answer
it's like I don't know most people
probably but like not everyone would
okay but most what did I ask most people
come on probably would find you more
attractive right
our physical state is too different I
don't support the mindset I don't think
you should be confident not that way I
think you should lose it I should think
you should be unconfident to lose it
and with that confidence she could use
that to get better yeah I believe that I
think I suppose I support that I could
use that together but but it maybe she
is and each step as as she takes she
might be on her way of losing but we
don't know that we don't know her life
we don't know but right now in this
specific moment she's happy with herself
and good for her and that's all I'm
supporting is she dropped 10 pounds we
don't know she might have been bigger
than that
you guys come up with these crazy
scenarios yeah but we're only looking at
it from how it is wait wait how much
bigger could she get
bigger bed bound who knows no but this
is what I'm saying it's like we're
supporting this and we're cheering or on
living in delusion it's delusion yeah
but the question was just hot I asked
why do we let women get to this stage of
delusion where you're saying I look good
today when you clearly don't everybody
in the room knows she doesn't you know
you wouldn't want to switch bodies with
her and it's like I think that honestly
a little bit of bullying is good for
people no it's not I I think from
bullying that's not good for your mental
health I think it's good for strong
people not everybody is though I don't I
don't
going through stuff can also cut you off
from your emotions you might actually be
too cough you might be hyper independent
that's actually not a good response yeah
that's not a good response you know I
think it was a great response when I was
when I when I was indirectly told I was
fat I ran a marathon and lost that
weight babe I'm just glad that happened
but it's like it's like this this
Society it's like we can't call spade a
spade
I think it's important to appreciate
what different people look like because
we actually can't help it all the times
yes okay weight is a bit different thing
but like we can't judge people's
appearance all the time because
sometimes it's not someone's choice I
think we should judge people's
appearances I don't think we should
judge anyone at all
only got judges man let's keep it on
that I think that you guys are liars
we have good standards but we've been
taught not to judge other people based
on their appearance
I I think that um you do judge people's
appearances every day just like you did
when we were talking about the dating
and you said you wouldn't date obese why
did you judge that's judger
absolutely different I'm not sitting
here watching
um putting up a photo and saying that
person's fat haha I'm not doing
right would you say that I am faster
because
because you know I was lighter
that's judging
yeah
and you're running against the fat
person of course so we are speaking on
facts and she put that picture up and
she asked that question it was a fact
that she is obese yeah
but I'm just praising her I'm praising
how she receives it I'm praising how she
sees herself and I agree and that's it
man that's and I agree with that that's
what I support that's what I think
you're praising delusion
not delusion it's just her loving
herself if she's paying for her own
health care why do we even care at all
like
why why do I care if she's obese
um her as a person I don't know her but
as a society I don't think we should be
promoting obesity I think that obese
people um take a toll on the Health Care
system and it's really hard on her
family like maybe if she has kids
siblings parents they're the ones that
are going to have to take care of her
therefore I think that is selfish to be
that obese if she has kids sorry even if
it's parents or they're not your parents
have to watch their kid I think it's
just her choice and if she's happy with
how she is then that's fine if she's not
happy how she is then you can pass
judgment
you could be trying to help her you know
you know what I'm saying if she's happy
if she's okay with it you know I I do
agree with it being posted on social
media be happy with that for yourself by
yourself
[Laughter]
because why why are we going to create a
community of feeling good being obese
knowing there's so much Health Challenge
my brother my brother there's a lot of
people I'm not talking about the
mentality as I say mentality why are we
promoting obesity knowing there's so
much health challenges behind it that's
like you're saying go have sex with
everyone at our condom but that's what's
being promoted yeah well we should be
wearing condoms don't bother us but that
doesn't get brought on this discussion
and and and and for me I just feel like
I know what you're saying
look listen go have sex with that girl
without a condom you'll see bro make
sure and wear your robots of course
would you you would tell your boy that
right
you don't want to hear but you're coming
on
look at your house yeah you got people
you gotta protect yourself that's what
I'm saying of course it's protecting
everybody else so yeah but my thing is
she's allowed to use social media how
she uses social media social media it's
up to her it's freedom of speech it's
Freedom of Choice it's free will if she
feels good good for her yeah but that's
no that's it that's why I think it's
more important that we shame it
um
wait wait wait that's what creates
mental health wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait and say and say put the
roles away we don't want to see that put
it away go get on the treadmill lose
weight
lose some weight and then come back my
mom used to tell me
my mom used to tell me and maybe
everyone's gonna say I was traumatized
that
you have to earn a bikini body and I
believe that I really do and I think you
should earn the right some people don't
want that though it's just up to them if
they don't want to I think I think we
need to please stop talking about
exceptions we want to talk about the
rule I I've said this I I've said to
friends that might be very overweight
like I think you would have a better
quality of life I think you would enjoy
it more that's as far as I'd go I would
never shame them for if that's still her
choice I saw her choice I'll do one more
I'll I'll have my overweight friends
um run up 21 flights of stairs with me
I think if you ask someone do you want
to lose weight
90 on 95 98. it will be yes
well if they don't and I've been there
I've been there
pal I've so when I was a teenager
because I'm very tall when I first had a
growth spent in height I was very very
skinny and I couldn't get really gain
weight it was extremely hard to me and I
hated it like I've been through that but
girls girls and stuff yeah would make
comments and stuff and it made me feel
so [__] so like I feel like there's
empathy that comes from that isn't it
isn't that like I did obviously try and
gain weight so I don't know if that's a
difference
basically bullying somebody encouraged
you to be a better person or change your
your ways or whatever to how they think
should be acceptable there are different
people there's the people that could
drive the mindset to get better yeah but
that's that's a different way people as
well
could break down exactly break them down
really bad blah blah blah and you know
you're not accepting this is the
difference is it body shaming to call a
spade a spade to say You're fat you are
fat like you are fat it's not it's not
to be mean but I mean then it's like
wait wait so it's like how do we fix
problems if we can't acknowledge they
exist this is the problem with the
delusion wait this is the problem with
the delusion of modern women it's like
we can't even acknowledge that there's a
problem how the hell do we fix it if we
can't even say hey the problem is there
yeah I am obese then you can at least
say maybe I should eat less maybe I
should get on the treadmill but it's
like tooth and nail I'm like pulling
teeth here trying to say yeah this is a
problem
but why is it out problem to fix
um why it's not your problem my is my
problems
[Laughter]
if we care about someone it is okay to
encourage them but we'll say you I think
we'll have a better quality of life
because this this and this because I
guess it could be from a caring
perspective but not shaming and because
some people do so find them desire we
don't need shame and also what about the
people the minority that can't help it
at least it makes them feel more
comfortable I don't think we needed to
go down to the shame inside like let's
be honest like you would talk to someone
about their obesity yeah the most
respectful exactly
aspect and you say I'm concerned maybe
think of that okay
but that's all you can do it's down to
that individual whether they want to
change their way or obese person as I
said 98 of them want to lose weight they
do want to lose weight if you talk them
you ask them a question do you want to
lose it they will say yes and they just
don't know how to so I am not trying to
stand up here and be like oh I am going
to support you being obese yeah I do
think we should shame them off the
internet
yeah no I don't think we should be
promoting that to kids so be honest I
think I disagree with kids are kids are
on the internet like I don't think we
should be promoting like fat chicks on
the covers of magazines I don't think we
should be promoting yes Queen that's a
good thing that you're obese like yeah
you do look good on social media there's
kids on social media what messaging are
we pushing and this is why this is why a
lot of women they get they get work done
and this is their exotic example if
you're going to push The Narrative of
because you need to be perfect then
you're gonna go do certain things to
your body because of idolization
let me let me respond to this okay women
get work done because they're lazy not
necessarily because some some women
lacking in in larger breasts or bigger
bomb and you're going to do that to
please the man or whatever you know what
I'm saying women okay sorry there's two
reasons one they want more attention and
the attention that they got and that God
gave them wasn't enough so they say let
me go get surgery so I can get more
attacks because it's pushed wait wait
wait wait wait wait I need you to I need
you to wait for one second and the
second reason is because they're lazy
and they'd rather get a BBL than go to
the gym I'm serious like they would
rather nutrition nutrition is hard right
nutrition's like the hardest part
is so hard nutrition is hard working out
every day is hard yeah um getting a
surgery is a cheat code yeah
um to a point now I think that is why
it's a good thing to celebrate
uniqueness and differences otherwise
everyone is pressurized to look the same
a certain way but my brother look I've
done personal training years ago yeah
yeah you're a person training at all can
you grow a bum can you you know can you
exercise and get the same bum as a bbo a
BBL yeah you could shape your bum you
could shape
you can grow your glutes a bit talk
about it comes with body fat right okay
so my point exactly is
this world is pushing women in like
front line to look a certain way to
dress a certain way and it makes little
girls on my daughter to look at them and
think I want to be like that I'm going
to reverse down here if I don't look
like that then I'm a piece of [__] and
I'm not gonna be desired by the demand
that I want or whatever and that's
that's a wrong narrative
the men are asking for this though the
men aren't asking for the botox they're
not asking for the bbls they're not
asking for the lip fillers let me just
do that [__] on their own and that's my
point but that gets glamorized when I
reverse this on like onto yeah you just
said that Society is pushing women to do
these things 100 right then that's the
reason why it would be Satish hidden
be on Instagram like that no I hear you
but what I'm saying same thing no but
I'm talking about something different so
I'm talking about the fact that a lot of
these women he just made a really good
point you should acknowledge that was
not really good no I understand but what
she was doing online was self-love it
had nothing to do with her body and how
she looks and she wasn't like oh look at
me I look like this she was just saying
look I feel good or whatever what she
said
that what I got from that video was
self-love and a lot of people don't love
themselves she wanted to say more about
I mean did you understand what I'm
saying it's self-love so if she's saying
okay but again it to me this goes to
delusion if she says I look good and she
clearly doesn't that is narcissism if
you say that I feel good and there's no
way in hell that you can be that big and
feel good
um you're a liar you're a big liar
um narcissistic and delusional you have
a high visceral fat which is going to
cause um
you also have to want to control people
you also normally hurt people it's not
just having self-love and also when you
people are bullied and they are made to
feel [__] about themselves actually that
can lead to narcissism because they have
to be the best all the time and they're
not kind or good to other people so you
had to tell them YouTube so I could help
them just seeing second this is why
we're here to tell them YouTube that
this is why I could help them also like
it might make I said the sport it might
make those minority people that can't
help but feel better it's kind of like
transgender like not everyone all having
different identities not everyone
probably does need to relate to a
different identity but I guess at least
the minority that are probably born of
the wrong time but then look but that
gets pushed more than obesity though
yeah that's a deep one that's a deep one
let's talk about that then because you
want to accept
transgender and stuff but you don't
wanna you know I don't want to accept
that either they scare me a bit Yeah but
but I don't but apparently but
apparently it's accepted apparently we
can't say nothing to them we can't have
an opinion oh I'll say something and
also let's talk about it please I want
to do a picture I do I do want to do a
panel with um some transgenders and I
want to do a panel with just obese women
so we can talk about these topics
that'll be very interesting
[Applause]
I'd love to be here too yes so so just
pearly things one dm me if you know any
in London I'm serious I want to do it
I'd love to work with you guys just just
transgenders just fat people we can talk
about these issues some people but it is
the minority they're generally born with
the wrong opposite chromosomes to their
genitals so that's completely
understandable but I think for example I
could be called a tomboy in some aspects
when I was younger I could have some
masculine energy but I would I'm still a
female like
but what makes you a female nowadays you
know what oh god oh let's talk about it
because nowadays here you can say who
you could be whatever you want I I'm a f
i i I'm a starfish
I'm a bird
what are you gonna say you gotta say you
know what I'm saying so nothing you
can't say nothing no more this is what
I'm saying this world is delusional you
can't say nothing you can't have an
opinion about nothing contribute to it
you absolutely contribute to it oh my
gosh during this whole conversation
contributing how
um by begging up a fat woman and saying
that she looks good when she does I'm
just glorifying how she how she
perceives herself it's a difference
ask you string questions do you
genuinely believe she feels good
genuinely I generally feel she feels
good okay that's how she feels I think
35 for 30 seconds if she feels that way
then that's that's how she feels
emotional judge that emotionally you
think you can feel good at it that way I
don't know
but if she feels happy within herself
good for her you think Jonathan I think
she's genuinely happy we don't know I
have no idea who knows that's what she's
presenting us who are we to Liars come
on sorry can I see that video One More
Time
One More Time
well if she has some guy she probably
does have guys going after her like some
guys because there's always a simp
somewhere yeah
turn on the how many views
how many views today
and just be like okay and what are
people saying in the comments
yeah
I can't read it this is on Twitter I'd
have to see you'd have to go to her
original okay to see her comments this
is conservative on Twitter
I need today
she said do you never get dressed and
just be like
damn I look good she's very pretty
um
can I just say what she she's saying
yeah I feel that you know you might have
your days where you don't feel good or
you may you know like you don't have a
haircut get a hair done or nails done or
whatever maybe today she felt good like
she got her hair done she got her nails
done she got a nice little dress on she
got her makeup on she feels better than
she usually does so good on her you know
what I'm saying that's all I could say
she looks good you want to know why
that's what she thinks she does she
thinks she looks good to herself okay
and that's good for her but here you see
you can't even you can't even lie I'm
like you she thinks she looks good you
can't even say she looks good so you
know it's yeah but but it goes by pers
it goes by preference so when I was
doing the chart she's not my preference
it doesn't mean that I'm discreeting how
she feels right but I might not be
attracted to white women Asian women
doesn't mean yes it's just my perception
or how I feel 100
of the people in this room said they
wouldn't date obese but that's a
different question no so you know that
it is not like the world does not accept
her but yet you continue to lie to her
and I think it's actually meaner to lie
than to tell the truth I think it's
meaner to push this stuff than it is to
be honest with somebody because if
you're honest about a problem we can fix
it but you lie and you lie and you lie
and you know it's a lie and that's a
crazy thing I've asked you guys
different questions in different ways
and you know it's not true I had two
aunties that died from obesity so this
is why I'm
oh my God said
obesity is not I think people need to be
warned about
um it's not a theme it's not uh
it's not something you should be
promoting it's not something you should
be supporting
she
thinks that she feels good but she
doesn't
she wants to feel good it's good that
what she's doing for her mental health
she's only person on social media chess
why sorry why do you think she's posting
it on social media
we are commenting on her reaction to how
she felt she looked good that's it
that's it that's it we're not making a
comment on whether we can see that she's
obese whether we like obese people okay
but comment in that she felt good she
expressed that and the level of
confidence is something to be okay when
you saw the video at first did you
notice her weight of course yeah okay
was it was it the first thing you saw of
course
energy if we didn't hear what she said
everything if we didn't hear what she
said yeah okay thank you thank you for
being honest right it was the first
thing you saw of course okay so you
don't think it's it's lying to like to
push this and say that's so great when
you know damn well it's the first thing
you noticed
yeah but it's it's it's like it's
someone's opinion it's like I'm looking
at the video and yeah we know she's
overweight
but I'm not looking and judging her
appearance I'm actually appreciating how
she stands for how she feels so every
question that's it I have a question
you're not judging her appearance um
could you tell if you found her
attractive or unattractive I already
said I don't I don't find oh okay so
that's a lie so you did Judge Her okay
so you did Judge her appearance because
you made a choice in your head
attractive or unattractive and the
weight was the first thing you noticed
so you could say and this is why I'm
saying like I hate lying because it's
like we're programmed to to not say what
we're all thinking because I did say
what we were thinking and at this point
it's like you want us to comment on her
you want us to comment on a way and
we're saying we're not doing that like
it's not a lie like we're saying that we
we write the way that she came in with
that energy and it's not the first her
weight wasn't the first thing that I
noticed because the video was her face
and her neck and her shoulders so why
would that be first thing that I saw it
was the energy that she was giving and
in this day and age
you don't see that many people with
confidence
I see so many women with delusional
confidence that's like so if you walk in
a room with a hundred thousands of it
was of her what what what what advice
would you give to them
and business no no I'm just saying
advice wise like what if there was to be
like if I was actually put in a position
where I had to tell me something that
that could motivate me tell me something
that could help me with my with my
lifestyle what what advice would you
give to that person I think it's
important that they're warned and
informed about that but surely they are
like everyone knows of course they've
got children they understand what
they're doing to their bodies they're
overweight they surely they understand
that how are they understand if everyone
lies to them through life no genuinely
like if they go through life and this is
the reactions they get how would they
really understand because we're humans
and we're individuals and who cares no
but I'm saying so so I'm saying if
everybody reacts the way you guys
reacted how would they know but if we're
talking about health issues and how they
know what's affecting their bodies
they're grown adults they must
understand regardless of what reactions
they are getting
they know as adults what they're doing
to their bodies it's got nothing to do
how are they now if nobody tells them
why would but how do we know that like
does that how would they know no how
would you know what I think it's through
education like probably how would they
get calories on menus now how would they
get educated if everybody lies
we know there's like obesity pandemics
through the news through education most
women that are surely they would have
gone to school
Works you're seeing that
how would she get better if everything
everybody around guys
and that's the problem is women we go
through life everybody lies to us they
don't tell us like they don't tell us
that geriatric pregnancy starts at 35
you have so much time they don't tell us
that yay you're not worth as much as a
single mother like to the dating Market
they don't tell us that hey when you're
fat you're not valuable like people
don't when people don't aren't as
attracted to you when you're overweight
like they just lie like we go through
society and everybody lies to women
instead of just telling us what it is
you can be valuable outside your weight
though I wouldn't like if any gym on my
arms smell and I want somebody to tell
me my arms modern to be honest
I do think it's a bit ridiculous is like
I don't know it's like the Western world
is just greedy in so many different
senses that that annoys me a little bit
like but then that's like places like
America the portions they do and stuff I
do think it's important that the
government do inform people when they do
make steps because it is do you think
it's like I think it's more on the
people
like to inform each other like I
genuinely think if you really care about
someone you're honest with them
and I I think it's like easier to just
say oh you go girl instead of saying hey
no get on the train do you genuinely
believe that these people do not
understand what they're doing and it is
all based on
reactions from other people
you don't know me you met me today
I'm telling you like I'm just making a
stupid scenario I'm gonna have sex with
this girl tonight
and I feel really good about myself that
I shouldn't wear a condom right this
girl has been around
having sex with other men why but I feel
good in myself that confident enough I
mean like anything I'm gonna have sex
without condom would you say go that's
not absolutely that's not the point that
I'm saying I'm saying as so okay
it's because it's supporting because and
also we talk about mentally and
physically as well but you are
responsible for your own actions
regardless what anybody says to you you
as a grown man are responsible for your
own actions no matter who is saying
whatever to you whatever advice you are
responsible same way she's responsible
for her while I agree with that you
didn't say to me that
because you feel good no problem
as long as you feel good point go ahead
and do what you have to do you want to
finish as long as you feel good go ahead
and do what you have to do because
that's not the point that I was actually
just
this time I was I the question that I
asked is do you actually really think
that she doesn't understand what she's
doing to herself being a responsible an
adult and about a responsible adult but
being an adult understanding the
consequences of her actions do you think
she doesn't understand the harm same way
somebody pointers our reaction to it
that's what I'm trying to get to is our
reaction to it your reaction to me will
be what because we reacted to her
we said that she feels confident she
feels good and that's all you care about
now I want your reaction what would your
reaction be to me
do your thing
it's not my business
knowing that it could be right if you
feel good if you feel good about
yourself knowing the risk if you not if
you as a grown man if you know the risks
of what you're getting yourself into it
is none of my business to be telling you
what you should or should not do if it
makes you feel good and you're coming to
me and say I feel really great about
this and if you see me so like posting
that kind of thing all over social media
like you wouldn't feel like why is he
posting all over social media is not
good for the world so what so what were
you trying to say wait wait so what
you're trying to say is she's if you
want to talk about this if you're
talking about this woman you know you're
trying to say that she should same team
let me just refresh let me just ask you
a question here and kind of what you're
saying yeah maybe I might be wrong but
correct me if I'm right yeah
are you saying that because she's obese
she should hide herself
she should feel oh I should feel every
bit disgusting as much as people think
that is
no no but I'm saying because she's out
there glamorizing herself feeling good
about herself but there's people that
are going to be very negative and trying
to pin her down into a position where
she should hide herself lock herself and
never come out and see the day of life
because she's so fat are you crazy what
I'm saying because I I say like no I'm
just saying
you correct me if I'm wrong as well
what she did what she could do it in a
different way where it could become more
positive and how so she's just she could
how she could start her journey that's
gonna help herself get better which is
going to motivate others just like her
to get better based on that you'd don't
know what she's doing you don't know who
she is a lot like her out there number
what I'm saying you're right but you're
missing a point she's motivating people
to love themselves she's showing you
that no matter how you look how dark you
are right you are how hairless you are
how harmless you are whatever the hell
you are all right
no no but let's be real yeah
I feel good forget all that yeah I feel
good yeah I feel good look I could say
that I'm an attractive man I can say
that
you may disagree you may disagree but I
feel that I'm I'm attractive I feel good
why would I let anybody else tell me
different man you get it man to man yeah
let me go back to this scenario that I
brought to her man to man are you gonna
tell me
do what you have to do me personally as
a man I wouldn't
because me as a man
I'll look out for you I'm an avocado
because you know the risk right I know
why are we taking that risk as a
positive but I'm looking as a different
form of positivity it's not her
appearance it's her inside it's her
spirit but we're talking body inside
it's not about we're looking at it
visually physically you know I'm looking
I'm listening to her her spiritually we
are you know saying to everybody in the
audience that I feel good and that's no
no there's no shame in that sorry that
is the inside as well
it is it physically is in there
in fairy sorry in a very risky condition
so the same way you will tell me bro
I do advise you to do that because you
know it risky it's the same way I'll
advise her not to do the same
yeah but and you wouldn't like me to go
promote
all my brothers listen feel confident in
yourself feel good on yourself go there
have sex with no country I think the
question is like would you guys
encourage your friend
to see that there could be a better
quality of life than because if this is
dualistic we're talking about two
different points because we we
appreciate that she's encouraging
everyone whoever you are to feel good
about yourself and that's important
no we don't want to
but yes we'd also want to encourage
someone in a in a career understand what
I just said I brought you so now you're
in the scene we I said I feel good about
myself I feel very important in doing
this you're compared to do it but you're
comparing an action to somebody that
actually is telling you how they feel
that's completely no I'm just telling
you I feel good about it yeah of course
but you're not you're missing a point
you're gonna do an action I think you're
missing the point actually no no but
he's making he's making bear points no I
don't how can I how respectfully I don't
understand your point reason being is
because you're you're saying you feel
good grass great yeah but you're also
pointing out a very big uh uh uh
curveball here you're saying you want to
have sex with a girl unprotected because
you feel good the intention is not good
but how you feel I can't I can't tell
you how you feel what's wrong because
how you feel but I can tell you that
what you're about to do isn't a good
idea that's my advice I love wages you
get what I'm saying
energy that we want to have yeah but
she's not saying that she's not asking
to lose weight she's just saying I feel
good no she didn't say she understand
she said I look good and that's her
feeling good no no and she said I look
forward we listen to what she said but I
look good but she says I look good
because she thinks she looks good that
means she feels she looks good so good
for her that's also mean that she gonna
continue doing what she's doing probably
not who knows and posting it and
bringing awareness did you see people
who look like her to be like her yeah
but it brings awareness to show that you
can love yourself or however however you
look it doesn't matter you know that's
what I can say Shea said as well she
might just feel good that day I'll be
appreciating how she looks that day
she's not saying like guys I'm obese and
I think it's a good thing and
30 seconds but what do you mean a lot of
them do like that's what we get like
plus size influencers plus size models
like it's becoming common and that's not
good for a society like can we agree
that's not good it's not good to have
more plus size unhealthy people that's
not a good thing in a society
I'm not saying that I agree with obesity
let me just say that would you say you
disagree with obesity I I disagree with
obesity because it is a health issue we
all know that we know that I'm not
basing that video upon her obesity I'm
looking at her inside I'm looking at her
heart how she thinks how she thinks that
she feels good that's it would you agree
that her heart is actually in a poor
condition that's not I wouldn't like it
please I wouldn't know it's about how
she feels please God
most likely they're inside I'm good well
of course that's clearly obvious okay
clearly obviously don't you think though
obesity is the the bar of the ABC is a
bit low like there's people that are
classed as obese that aren't that big I
think that actually most people that are
obese don't even know they're obese yeah
like because and I actually think that
like a lot of girls think they're in
shape yeah
no I like I think there's like a lot of
girls like it's weird they'll think
they're normal size and I'm like I'm
looking at you you're overweight like
it's very obvious so what's normal size
to you
um what would you consider that normal
size I'm healthy BMI no but like like
size wise for a woman like obviously
you've got plus size and you go yeah I
wouldn't know so I mean you guys sizes
run a little different here but I would
say
uh depending on a girl's height like
eight size eight or lower that's quite
small I wouldn't say anything right size
but I I have a friend too you guys you
guys's stuff runs differently the sizes
she she has um
a good big ass but she's really tiny in
the rest of her frame and I think she
told me she was classes obese which is
awesome her lower body yeah well and
yeah not even her legs that much
some some people getting their legs they
bomb their hips people get in different
areas
I mean yeah just yes I just think the
bars are a bit low oh this conversation
is so amazing
very interesting you know what it's
interesting because it's different
opinions and that's what I can say I
can't say that you're wrong and I I I
thank you and that's all I can say you
know what I'm saying and that's your
opinion as well and my opinion is I feel
like you guys look wrong that think the
overweight straight away I feel that you
know how she thought overweight straight
away yeah I'm talking about her I'm
talking about the video the video the
message that she gave in that video was
the fact that she accepts how she looks
and she feels good about it that's it
you know what I'm saying
okay I'm gonna read the Super Chat we
also needed Pearl history facts some of
us on some subjects we all agreed with
each other pretty much
who agreed with me though I just want to
know in it on a level
I don't think I agreed with a single
thing you said tonight okay that's fine
that's fine do you agree so you know I
agree that I appreciate it yeah I really
appreciate it
I agree with you on the the court stuff
we agreed remember I was talking about
the message yeah
there's so many examples of
it
respect there's different walks of life
you can't judge somebody and we haven't
walked their walk you haven't you can't
judge that that person I think everybody
judges everyone I think I'm the nicest
because I'm honest about it where I
think everyone else is a liar
yeah that's fair enough yeah now
um Lawrence Bullock thank you so much
Lawrence if body positive positive
positivity is good why does it only
apply to women if it were a man on Tick
Tock that it would be met with jokes
what a great Point Lawrence Manny F this
panel would dislike David Goggins taking
Souls Goggins
I think I said his last name wrong and I
don't want to hear about it uh Lawrence
the Obesity discussion illustrates why
women in Stamps want to be lied to they
don't value the truth they value the
delusion of feeling good
bunk I'm sorry this they're coming for
the couch uh most delusional panel on
the couch yet send the astronaut I think
he meant asteroid but it was a spelling
error
um Dan uh
Lawrence block was traumatizing is
listening to that guy on the couch black
Moses the real reason the reason why men
don't talk about their problems is
because women use them against them
Lawrence there's currency in being a
victim that's why there's an increase in
people going to therapy Jessica my
fiance used to listen to you and I got a
little jealous when he said he agreed
with a lot of what you said and then I
started listening and I became hooked
you got you have helped me become a
better wife and a mother
Jessica that's nice uh subscribe to wife
school
um I recently put out a video where I
learned how to cook for a family of four
in a day Joey British Dave East is
light-skinned tatted or pearly whites
look and looks like he's six foot or
more trying to tell himself he'll move
to girls that have hit the wall would be
um wall the same he would to younger
chicks l-o-l what was that faster
what I can say it again hold on I'm not
always the best Super Chat reader I get
a lot of complaints for it so let me go
back
um David British Dave East
is a light-skinned is he talking about
you I don't know I don't know yeah he's
a bit above my I don't know who the
Davis is
light-skinned tatted and with pearly
whites and he looks like he's six foot
or more trying to tell himself he'll
move to girls that have hit the wall the
same he would have to younger chicks
because you said you date 50 year olds
or you would
he's a bit of a Capper we he's a cool
guy a bit of a Capper I like you but a
Capper a little bit who me uh yeah you I
like I like your cool guy but I just
there's been so much cap tonight
it's just been like an exhausting like
cap cap it's just it's just opinions and
I mean yeah I know you know that obesity
between male and females the pro the
reason why it's more celebrated than
women is because we do have more
pressure in terms of the way we look
okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna obliterate
that with just one fact